many private universities depend heavily
on blank the wealthy individuals who
support them with the gifts and bequests
so whatever blank is that's they're kind
of saying well another way of describing
blank is that they're the wealthy
individuals who support them with gifts
and bequests so which of these words are
the best or best represent wealthy
individuals who would support a private
university with gifts and bequests
so the instructors they would teach at
the university but they're not they're
they don't tend to be wealthy and they
don't tend to be giving
giving large gifts or even be giving
gifts at all they take a salary from the
university so i would i would rule out
the instructors the administrators well
these are the people who kind of
run the university but once again they
don't they don't tend to be wealthy and
they don't they don't tend to give gifts
to the university donate money to the
university so i will
i will rule that out monitors well to
monitor something would be to kind of
observe something see what's going on
that doesn't really mean giving to
something so i would i would rule that
out
accountants well these are the people
who take account of things they're the
ones who kind of keep track of of of the
books who who keep track of the money
for uh well for any organization in this
case maybe university but once again
they're not the wealthy individuals who
would support the university with gifts
and requests so i'd rule those out
so i've ruled out all the choices so we
we should hope that it's going to be
benefactors and and benefactors make
sense because notice it has the word it
has the word
bena well you don't see exactly the word
benefit you see the word benefact but
it's really coming from the word benefit
and if you're
benefiting someone that means you're
doing something for them so a benefactor
is someone who's doing something for in
this case a
a private university so i would
definitely go with benefactors and you
could put it back in the sentence and
see that it actually sounds quite quite
right many private universities depend
heavily on benefactors the wealthy
individuals who support them with gifts
and bequests you could almost say many
private universities depend heavily on
benefactors the wealthy individuals who
benefit them with gifts and bequests